herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute hier stehen wieder in der
küche und ich habe mal wieder was
vorbereitet wie seht ihr 61 die ja
irgendwie dinge wo ich her gesehen und
musste ich mitnehmen also einfach eis
zum selbermachen aber wir machen
natürlich auf diesem kanadier nicht
einfach normal das eis selber probieren
heute verrücktes variationen aus und
testen ob es funktioniert und b schmeckt
dafür habe ich heute sagen vorbereitet
haben wassermelone die wenn derart klein
schneiden klein hacken play dienste mit
wasser auffüllen oder so dann machen wir
aus wassermelonen ein eispalast damit
und dann wäre hier eine herbstes als ich
glaube das ist eine sache die es gar
nicht
hertha ist neben dieser schweren sterne
ganz bewusst dafür sondern so eine
geisterhafte sind unsere namen dafür
gazpacho gazpacho das pc adventure das
bad immer neu und yahoo und co
da haben wir hier nutella leute ich
glaube jeder von euch wollte schon mal
mit teller essen oder hab schon ein
aber das wird zeit und nun kehrt dann
haben wir hier das wird pervers aber das
wird das schlimmste wir haben keine boni
warum hatte wohl keine ahnung wer ist
also die letzte sache die man
in dem spot wird das natürlich sagt
unglaublich ich glaube das könnte selbst
in seinem ist so kalt ist und gefroren
darf immer scharf wird gerechnet
danach wie ketchup ich habe auch keinen
anderen kategorien wird testen ist aus
das stelle ich mir gerne vor ort müsli
weil überlege mal deutlich ich glaube
jeder erkennt dass man macht sich
registriert und so gerade weil die
schoko müsli dann wird er die milch
schokolade
das heißt wer in so schokoladige milch
drin so komisch stücke sind
bin gespannt ich würde sagen alles
erklärt legen wir los ich würde sagen
anfang an mit wasser - oder wie es
köstliche als vorzubereiten filetieren
wir zunächst sich fast ohne uns in die
hände so schneiden in aller welt
schneidet so was mitunter die antwort
ist ja
ich glaube das war schon das herz
gebrochen wir gar nicht hier kommen wir
jetzt erstmal so noch ganz klassisch
schön kochen und hier liegt jetzt
wirklich erträgt die wassermelone so
klein wie möglich zuschneiden die
wahrscheinlich erst einmal leute von
daher denke ich jetzt nicht irgendwie
ich würde es so tun ist eine ahnung wo
wir schneiden das jetzt ganz kleine
fühle mich langsam
es war erst das zweite video kann man
durch aber wieder so einen kopf stellen
mit so einem messer die leute haben uns
entschieden wir probieren das jetzt
einfach weil ich habe jetzt einen
gefüllt das heißt am 8
und jetzt fühlen wir das hier ein so war
leute werden nur eins ist fertig okay
leute das erste eis fertig was nehmen
als nächstes werden jede menge
möglichkeiten für sagen wir machen mal
was hier einfach da müssen wir nicht
besonders schlimm macht und das wissen
habe ich vor allem nur es gibt ja auch
leute die würden am liebsten im sondern
nur eis essen meine das ist
wahrscheinlich das perfekte herzhafte
vollwertige essen für sich bedeutet das
ist schon so richtig glücklich bleiben
wir bei extrem als nächstes nehmen wir
die pepperoni ich bin gesellig man doch
dass in jüngerer weise geil schmecken
kann
ich habe das in letzter zeit halte mich
da wohl nicht so beim nachschuss oder
sowas aber in 1 alter ich möchte die
nummer eins ich einfach ein bisschen
kleiner zu probieren die scharfe
splitter ticker schafft
[Musik]
was mir gar nicht würde ich sagen und
dann mit handys dazu sollte ich besser
beschriften die einzelstücke das alles
nur zwei ich weil die nichtwähler sind
wären so ein alter wo das wird aber es
ist ein experiment wie viel zeit muss ja
nicht alles perfekt schmecken oder beruf
sei genauso wie man aus verrückten dinge
als nummer zwei leute ich glaub tricks
verbrauchen wird man hier irgendwas was
richtig gut schmeckt und ich glaube nur
kenner irgendwie nicht im stich lassen
ich war so gespannt das funktioniert
auch das glas leer schon ziemlich alt
was hat sie davon wenn du die täler in
die mikrowelle stellt damit die schmelze
der tech sektor besser aus und ist dann
die geschleusten felder hat man nicht so
mega drive und kurz und wenn ich mal
sterbe
schön waren jetzt nicht übermäßig
flüssigkeitsscanner europa sorgt der
firma
das heißt der scheiße scheiße es nicht
von bäumen auf rädern
was wir wollen ist er hoffe dass das im
osten sagt er sondern ein
das sind leute die sehen teller weiter
verbrannt wir steigen jetzt um auch das
hier gerne wenn du siehst und sowas
nicht verwendet habe ich glaube für das
neue einfach einmal hier so ganz
klassisch und so wenig sagen hast du die
klassische zubereitung das machen die
meisten sollte jeden tag deswegen muss
ich versprechen wir uns einfach so rein
das gefühl schmeckt lecker und raucht
aber so gar nicht machen es uns wieder
ein haus gibt ja ketchup chips es gibt
catcher nudeln jetzt auch ganz einfach
ganz entspannt okay leute ketchup ist
gefühlt ich sagen wir machen catcher
besteht ihr sowieso aus 60 70 prozent
zucker 21,9 prozent und kommen wir zum
letzten wo ich wirklich wirklich denke
dass mit gail benehmen hat ringo linie
unsere reich bekannten mixa ein so leute
sitzen müsli kommt hier nicht es geht
dazu haben beide keine richtigen mit
deckel drauf stark drauf
[Musik]
und jetzt das ist ja eine delikatesse
macht man folgendes ist man schritte
ganz klasse die milchmenge rein und dann
ein köstlich kommen auf 14 1
ohnehin ist das heißt über den am
meisten denke das könnte wirklich etwas
schmeckt es könnte gut werden perfekt
dass letztlich das heißt die
vorbereitungen sind geschafft gleich nur
noch probiert packen stellen seit wochen
dann sehen wir ein paar schon wieder
leute dieses jahr ist ein neuer tag die
sachen dürfen jetzt gefroren sind ich
habe die ganze zeit noch nicht
nachgeschaut und wir gucken jetzt 23 und
probieren also alles steht wie es sollte
an seinem platz
wir wollen das mal gespannt ob die
sachen überhaupt rauskommen so sachen
wie nutella gesetzt frage das gericht
erklärt bekommen die raus erklärt das
ist totaler das sieht man sonst habe ich
echt keine ahnung was was ist könnte es
auch schon auch blind probieren aber das
wird selbst zu krass ist ein märchen
erster das erste eis machst du aufhören
so ein bisschen einsam ist auf jeden
fall sehr alt wirklicher weise seine
ganze der spülmaschine müssen wir sehen
was dann wird sich das bestimmt treffer
eins sieht eigentlich lecker lecker
deutschen mitteln rief euro an ledige es
ist halt der normale catcher koch aber
das falsche das ist ein altes bald ich
teste ob man aus ketchup eis machen
seite wo es defizite
das ist so lecker das schmeckt überhaupt
nicht gut geschmeckt voll scheiße aber
wie gut ist einmal funktioniert hat ist
einfach perfekt ist und das könnte
neben sagt nein er ist dass er bereits
personal hat er einfach nur knapp
schaffen vermag es geht raus sie dir
direkt auf das ist das jetzt vergessen
wassermelone und nein es ist keine pasta
mit
es ist das pesto also das machst du aber
es ist besser wenn ich auf jeden fall
besser ist es wirklich so gazpacho er
kam sogar unsere geist mir super
vielleicht ist das einfach der snack
geht leute in zukunft an heißen tagen
wie diesen tut deshalb tut es wirklich
folgen ist ohne wird können wir das in
so einem sternerestaurant stattfinden
wir haben also neuesten berichte
vorstellen dass man so super spielt und
bekommst als fortschreitet und die
gaddafi leute hier sind 300 euro hört
sich erst mal aus dem feiern so richtig
trinken das ist besser als das
kaffeehaus ist immer noch ein herzhaftes
also würde noch nicht in den guten
bereich gehen aber es ist schon echt
interessant halte wenig leute ich glaube
ja bestimmt alle schon so ein bisschen
drauf gewartet dass nutella eis wir sind
so gespannt ob das schmeckt alter das
wäre ich meine arbeit so ungesund wenn
man einfach nur ein ice mit nutella sei
es wird aber ich weiß dass es richtig
war
ich glaube dass sie von dem geschmack
von un ermittlern das fett und so die
richtige temperatur hat mal gucken
bekannt ist aber warmen teller auch
crêpes oder so schmeckt auch nicht
nichts drin gelassen aber ich hatte das
ja mit dem messer so reingeschoben
scheinbar nicht ganz durch es sieht geil
aus ich probiere leute die konsistenz
ist es sowieso eiskonfekt so bisschen
cremig wie ein komplexes zutrifft dann
wird mir das vorgestellt dass man
erfährt ein führt also mittels brief ist
das merkt wie gästen das ist geil man
das ist echt geil da kommst du nicht
raus muss das alte probieren ja man also
das ist ungewiss sagte feldmann muss man
kriegen kann
aber das ist wirklich lecker empfehlung
ist da wie eis konfekt und dann danach
wie nutella was sich aber kraft finde
ist dass das irgendwie nicht so kalt
wird also gefühlt ist jetzt nicht so ein
normales weiterzieht beimischen als
wären wir jetzt so kalt ist und so aber
das wird irgendwie nicht so kalt jetzt
auch wie ganz aus so sind sie doch ein
bisschen zu null verharren eure liebe
leute das muss jetzt wirklich das würde
das nicht wirklich so ausgesetzt ist das
parken kostenlos richtig frisch
geschnittene wasser mit ohne dass sogar
das ist richtig gut leute in der berge
sehen dafür braucht man nicht viel
das ist ganz klar nicht im wasser
gewesen kein zuckerzusatz ist ein
richtig geiles erfrischendes süßes alles
okay sebastian auch das vergnügen das
wasser bildung als probieren gerade da
ich das ist nicht echt richtig schickt
ist wie süß das ist ja also ich muss
sagen ich finde es nicht extrem süß also
gerade jetzt mit nutella es kommt ja
martine leicht gesüßt ganz ganz klar
nächstes als leute was haben wir noch
nicht alle appelle und wir haben noch
komplex auf minister komplexes ist es
gerade auch wieder mit dem verlauf weil
das stehe er kopfüber drin dass die
ganzen schaffen für den fünf stücke sind
in der spitze
jetzt probieren werden wir bei geil aus
riesenhuber das recht stark ein bisschen
an bayern 1 sascha extrabreit
das bisschen mein ganzer mund doch wer
wirklich das ist ein klares und brennend
das ist so schade
die sind halt auch an sich
logischerweise aber das ist so richtig
kuriert konzentriert in der spitze mit
im kern das ist übel zum schluss das
müsli angespannt das kann sich sehen
lassen bücher der bibel als richter hat
diese diese millimeter man das
verbrennen ist eine sache bereue ich nur
man sie ist da um an der spitze wir
haben das repariert dadurch sieht man an
der spitze oben sind so ganz viele
kleine pünktlichen drin
und wie fühlen sie komisch erlaubte
zunge aber so der geschmack vom eis
richtig nah ist ja leute war ein mega
spannungs experiment ist war nicht so
bald die über interessante oder die auch
richtig lecker waren zum teil deshalb
wenn ihr darunter zwei mal schreibt die
kommentare erstmal dankeschön fürs zu
sehen wir sind zunächst mal wieder und
bis dahin tschüss